stephen good to see you how are you good
carlos how are you ma'am
very good thanks for making the time
today this show is
explosive and it continues to be so
in the second season i know that you you
know um
when it was sort of presented to you in
the beginning there was a plan for
how far this show was going to go did it
go into the second season and beyond
yeah there's a one two three definitely
you know
there's um you know what
what happened how it's going you know
one of those pictures
yeah i've started how it's going and
there is a plan
should amazon or anybody decide to to go
further we
we don't know yet but um there is a plan
for
you know when the audience meets robin
she is she's at the top of her game
you know she's completely in control
as far as everyone is concerned around
her but she's not
you know she's been dealing with issues
and
and just managing to sort of build a
smoke screen in front of her for her
for her whole working life and and we
get to see some of that in the second
season we get to see her
mom and and that relationship
and how that came about and and what
that has done to her and
and there's like hints at other little
moments of things
that we sort of understand who she is
and why and we also see
stuff that's going on with her sister
you know it's
so yes we did know it's but it's
it's pretty out there yeah places we go
to
yeah you know but it's still very funny
dark but funny and that's and that's a
big part of that draw
you know i think what i was curious
about was like what do you love about
telling this story in that there are
dark things in it but you're bouncing it
with all this humor
and it also seems absurd but we know
from reading headlines that it's
actually
not that absurd like the situations that
a lot of clients are getting into
everything everything we do is based in
some truth
every character has you know is is an
amalgamation of things that we've read
about
and ollie who's created and ollie comes
and pitches ideas to us
and of of of you know it's a big there's
a there's a long sort of
ideas board of the sort of things that
have happened in real life
you know i read about this happening in
you know australia and i and i thought
this was a really funny story from
you know india or whatever and so
and so he'll he as he sees kind of
interesting crazy stories that are
happening to celebrities around the
world
he writes them down and he comes to us
and he sort of then builds like a
character
around to maybe one or two or three
ideas so that it's not one
specific person when an idea is brought
so when an idea is brought to you you
know that seems kind of crazy
that he said i read do you ever double
check and go i have to see this for
myself
well i'll be honest with you there's
stuff that
that we already know about there's stuff
like
where you can look at the thing and go
oh this is that person
true i'm not going to say that out loud
but
but sometimes it's pretty clear yeah
whether it be somebody who's like
purporting to be in the first season
um green and organic and only using
you know and products that haven't been
tested on animals who's
and and you know live your life be
yourself and is having a nose job
you know and pretending that her husband
hit her
you know what right it's it's
we take the idea of something that's
happened and then we sort of stretch it
to the extreme so that it kind of feels
this can't be real can it
but we kind of know that it is yeah this
is true
if you could describe in a few words
your onset working relationship with
anna
how would that be what would those what
would those words be
uh comfortable relaxed
um trusting um
ultimately she she knows that i'm not
going to
do anything i'm going to push her
and and and my episodes this season are
very dark and we knew that and it was
one of the reasons that i
did them because i was actually doing a
different job i was in canada actually i
was in calgary
right i knew i was coming back to do
these two episodes and um
and then and and she goes she goes to a
very dark place and so it was a
it for me it was good for her having me
there because
she knows i'll look after her when it
gets back and and
anna lives it and it goes for it she's
there's you know there's no
anna goes to the place yeah what i think
is really
interesting about the about this show
and
both of your work on this show is that
though this
you know those big headline scandals are
things that we read about
but you are closer to it than say for
example i am
right and you have the experience of
interacting with an audience that might
not be appreciative of
what you do in life what you've done who
you are
yeah and so you know we're talking about
pride month and um anna had just posted
a really wonderful post but there are
people that don't understand
and there are people that that take have
a really bad take on it
yeah how do you what are the discussions
like among you two about that and how do
you support each other through things
like that
well there's nothing that we don't share
knows every single thing that there has
ever ever
i have done or or has happened to me or
you know
obviously sometimes you kind of don't
remember
just purely because it but we are very
very transparent with each other so i
knew who she was when i met her i knew
how she felt about things our political
and
and activist activism ideals
are completely aligned um
so so i'm very
i'm very proud of her and who she is and
and and i
and i stand behind it i i i'm not as
active
on the social network stuff and it's
purely because
i'm just doing other things it's you
know that's all i'm sort of
elsewhere um so sometimes she'll go oh
did you see what i said today
and i'll go no
and you know i think one of the things
that anna enjoys about the
about about social networks is that you
get to speak
directly to the people who are there you
know they're they're not you're not
trusting a journalist
to with some heartfelt stuff and then
the journalist writing their version of
it
you get to be your own authentic self
and and my wife is
very authentic
and i love her yes that's fantastic
steven thank you so much for this time
um congratulations on the show i hope
you can see more thank you
thanks